thomas mulcair courtise la métropole
albertaine courtisent surtout le maire
de calgary le 6 populaire narines henchy
le chef du npd se présente comme un
partenaire à long terme tout pour
rassurer l'électorat rassurer c'est bien
l'objectif premier de son cadre
financier le plan du npd est un plan
réaliste et se base le long terme un
plan équilibré prudent ajoute celui qui
est désigné comme un futur ministre des
finances néo-démocrate loin du statu quo
des conservateurs et de la pallée
libéral affirme andrew thompson le npd
mise donc sur 7 milliards de dollars par
an de nouveaux revenus
oui haussera les impôts des sociétés
annulera certaines baisses d'impôts des
conservateurs une question de priorité
affirme guy caron en une année monsieur
apple voudrait dépenser autant sur le
fractionnement du revenu que le npd a
l'intention d'investir au total dans les
garderies les infrastructures et le
logement abordable
n'empêche pour réussir à équilibrer ses
finances la part du lion de ces nouveaux
investissements est reportée dans les
dernières années de son mandat
les garderies à peine 250 millions de
dollars l'an prochain
et c'est dans la bonification des
transferts en santé que le npd va piger
pour financer toutes les promesses
faites plus tôt cette semaine vous le
laissez faire des choix et ce sont les
choix que nous présentons devant la
population canadienne pour le parti
libéral le plan du npd c'est de la
poudre aux yeux
monsieur mulcair tente de faire croire
aux canadiennes et aux canadiens qu'ils
obtiendront de l'aide immédiatement en
fait le npd a choisi de remettre à plus
tard la mise en oeuvre de la majorité de
ses promesses malgré tout juste être
dont ne se sent pas prêt c'est du tout
de présenter son propre cadre financier
nous étions le premier parti à établir
son sont à son cadre fiscal pour cette
campagne pour gouverner qui consiste de
trois années de déficit modeste et de l'
équilibre budgétaire atteint en 2019 et
avant même que le npd est présenté ces
chiffres le parti conservateur
les attaques est limpide elle a déjà
commencé avec les engagements qui mènera
à la perte de trois sont 1000 emplois
pendant une période d'instabilité
économique mondiale la table est mise
pour le débat de judy sur l'économie oui
emmanuel débat économique demain donc à
calgary où vous êtes
avec ce cadre financier tendent à 1000
cas arrivent donc assez préparés pour
parer aux attaques que ça va
certainement lui donner des assises plus
solides un identifiant des sources de
revenus des postes de dépense un surplus
donc une marge de manoeuvre voudrait que
les avantages de ce cadre financier pour
thomas mulcair c'est que ça précise ses
choix ses priorités et ça lui donne des
outils pour essayer de convaincre les
électeurs
un peu inquiet que le npd d'aujourd'hui
c'est pas un [ __ ] de nos grands parents
si vous voulez lance les impôts des
sociétés à 17% pas à 24 25 % les
priorités traditionnelles comme l'aide
internationale
on repousse en même temps il lui faut
maintenant convaincre les électeurs que
pour des enjeux comme garderie santé
infrastructures que ça vaut la peine
d'attendre à la fin de mandat ça s'est
pas fait et là où il demeure le plus
vulnérable c'est sur ses prévisions de
croissance et sont scrutés
la lutte il est loin d'être claire qui
s'est pas montré trop optimiste